things to get from a new york deli part
three let's get it today we're making
chopped cheese let's get it you want to
go to the deli you want to ask them for
a chopped cheese on a roll with onions
and blue peppers some people don't like
onions green covers but if you like
onion you can cover it
get american cheese
you can put white american too that
that's that's fire too
man isn't ketchup you could put barbecue
sauce instead of ketchup too it's fine
it's all fire
some people don't like tomatoes but for
less tomatoes um salt and pepper or
vinegar
or i'm gonna be like that's like they
that's it that's it
that's it make sure you got the bev
how to make the best
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay today we're making mozzarella
sticks you want to get your breadcrumbs
put them in a bowl get your flour in
another bowl
two eggs with a little bit of milk and
then mix that up
and make sure you got three different
bowls first put your muscle stick in the
flour then put it in the egg
then put it in the crumbs then you want
to put it back in the egg
and then you want to put it another time
in the crumbs
and then you want to take it and put it
in hot oil
just like that make sure the oil is hot
and then take it out
put it in a bowl
you want to get some fries whatever you
want
get your sauce i put chipotle sauce and
make sure you got the bev
noodle put some oil in your pan
some onions garlic let it get let it get
brown on the pan on the oil like that
put some tomato paste mix it all in
put some hot pepper soy sauce
not too much mix it all in
[Music]
put some water on there and now you want
to put your noodles in there
you want to put some uh garlic powder
and paprika so you can make it a little
more spicy if you want let it cook put
it all in the plate get some boiled eggs
put some parsley on top
and get some lime you can squeeze it on
top
well that's fine how to make chicken
quesadilla style
the chicken seasoned right
[Music]
now the cheese melted put the chicken on
top
salt pepper or vinegar
then fold it in half like a moon
full range on the side
[Music]
you